the 10 miners have been trapped
underground for almost two weeks they
were digging for coal in cohuila in
mexico when a tunnel wall collapsed and
the shaft was flooded
rescue workers have been pumping water
out of the mine families are frustrated
at how long it's taken
they must work day and night they
shouldn't stop but they do because the
pumps get blocked if the men are alive
they must be desperate it's too much
that is why we're speaking out because
we want help
more than 300 soldiers and other
emergency services personnel including
six military scuba divers have joined
the effort
rescue workers are hopeful water levels
may soon be low enough to enter at least
one of the flooded shafts
the rescuers have assessed the
conditions underground they have gone
down a significant part of the shaft but
they have not reached the bottom yet
mexico's main coal producing region has
seen a series of fatal mining accidents
over the years
the worst was in pastor de conscious in
2006 killing 65 people only two of the
bodies were retrieved
i won't live here until my brother is
found i don't want the same thing to
happen as in pasta the controls my
cousin was trapped there and they never
got him out so many accidents like this
happen in the mines and the government
does nothing
here in gohuila five miners were able to
escape but no contact's been made with
the men left behind
all their families can do now is hope
they're found alive
victoria gatenbee al jazeera